tausende menschen feiern auf mallorca
aber nicht am ballermann sondern so
feiert mallorca weihnachten auf der
balearen insel feiern die menschen das
weihnachtsfest traditionell in der nacht
zum dreikönigstag mit einem gigantischen
festumzug dass trotz corona es herrscht
fröhliche partystimmung auf mallorca die
heiligen drei könige ziehen überall
durch mallorcas dörfer von zahlreichen
geschmückten festwagen werfen sie
süßigkeiten in die reihen der zuschauer
das ganze erinnert stark an die
deutschen karnevalsumzüge mit dem
unterschied dass es sich hierbei um die
karawane aus dem morgenland handeln soll
trotz der korona pandemie nehmen ganze
menschenmassen an der prozession teil
die inzidenz auf mallorca aktuell über
850 doch auch trotz der korona pandemie
ist es für die kinder wieder das
highlight zum jahresbeginn